hey reject nation it's Greg elbow I'm
John we are going to watch a patron
video request from the man who always
requests the same channel to always
check out it's a good channel the
channel I personally enjoy watching
constantly a mixed feedback from the
reject nation on what they think of
watchmojo.com but an interesting list
coming at us
top 10 actors who have never been
nominated for an Oscar let's see let's
see I bet there's gonna be some
honorable mentions from luck they should
on the list let's go some Andrew Hayes
Andrew my buddy mutt dude this guy is
gonna be the next Wolverine why cuz he's
three foot six and he's stocky and shaft
he's jacked he's on his way to being the
sexiest man alive Andrew you should
check out his YouTube channel it's
called Andrew Hayes he does some great
movie reviews it's got really knows his
stuff he's got a lot of personality and
enthusiasm I really love this guy hell
of a lot every time we talked to him and
he's gonna be out here in September so
you best believe you and I are hanging
out buddy you've been a loyal patronage
act since the beginning of our patreon
page and yeah that deserves more than me
just buying you a cup of tea at our
local Starbucks
you deserve a starburst as well winning
one of these things is hard drink that
potion I can never grow even never even
in contention
I shall conquer ice arise welcome to
watchmojo.com innate if you were an
Oscar
myself I think kissing boys since I was
knee-high that's the point for this list
we've looked at any actor or actress
regardless of era or genre and have
ranked the most talented never to have
been given an academy award seth rogen
you know you said i had a magical glow
but that's it's you you're the one that
jeff daniels wasn't never tenth
jeff daniels that's probably why
well we can see the Dumb and Dumber
greatness what's really stupid is Jack
Daniels general lacks of nomination you
wouldn't try to look so innocent unless
you were guilty you're gonna have to
take my word for you you have no other
choice his cinematic breakthroughs came
in the oscar-winning terms of endearment
which he didn't receive a nod and he
since collected alternative nominations
throughout his career most notably for
1985 Purple Rose of Cairo and 1986 is
something wild he was shortlisted for a
Best Actor Golden Globe what about Devin
number two number nine John Goodman he
needs somebody who's ready to put their
name on it he hasn't widely respected as
one of the finest that is shocking
generation good enough for the Academy
well you know it just feels like one of
those days that starts off with a hearty
breakfast and as with some guy in the
news saying before turning the gun on
himself best known for playing Dan
Connor on the TV series Roseanne
Goodman's big screen highlights include
roles and Oscar hyped heavyweights the
artist Argo songs go items languishing
like he should have been Dominator tank
overfilled Lane
he's also often been linked to the Coen
Brothers movies and has starred in voice
acting roles for Disney and Pixar what
more does he need to do number eight
Steve Buscemi
oh boy square are we square another
regular collaborator with the Coen
brothers though Steve Buscemi often
isn't cast in a lead role it's quite
incredible that he's never made a
supporting I'm more like Seymour in
Ghost World and Carl Showalter in Fargo
is a big joke here
for Ghost World it was also an officer
say send me seem to pick up every
possible nomination apart from an
Academy Award
what are you kids without you Jesus
Christ move it the guy is meek talent
and surely it's about time you got
recognized know we're sitting on 4
million pounds of fuels like I keep
backing it up in the footage Shira
movies that they wouldn't get me no
kisses
number seven mia farrow don't marry poor
boys - it gets me which girls don't
marry Mia Farrow's filmography reads
like a rock under appreciate a
Rosemary's Baby all roles in The Great
Gatsby and death on the Nile could and
probably should also gotten her a chance
at the golden statuettes Rosemary's Baby
definitely [ __ ] Jackie okay an all-round
Hollywood icon as well
Carol is undisputed acting royalty but
there's a gap on her resume that really
shouldn't be there but I can't see them
I'm not even Leo Holly number six Raul
Julia don't you know what the Nazis did
to people my shoes almost touches a
stage better turned Hollywood star who
was critically acclaimed by most movie
commentators at least Raul Julia was
never able to convince the Academy let's
show a clip from The Addams Family and
then overdrawn his memory bank
probably best known as lovable scare
stir gomez addams in the out of span
that's not what I know Maz the Spider
Woman and a 1994 TV movie the burning
season Frankenstein on screen we're not
to the panel man which one was that
petrified to pick a number five
Martin Sheen what oh damn up so fast in
Vietnam you needed wings to stand by he
was president is hard to beat and he's
worked with the very best in the
business but still no nomination for
Martin Sheen oh that is a shot are you
there's a whole lot of other boys out
there waiting for you Badlands
Apocalypse Now The Departed the list of
great films in which he's featured is
phenomenal Steven Spielberg has directed
him Martin Scorsese Francis Ford Coppola
and Richard Attenborough
[Music]
I'm adding one we need Andy yeah but
none could land him acknowledgement from
the Academy same question for you number
four Jim Carrey my best Connery's of all
time of the numb and dumber double act
it's not surprising that a nomination by
now I mean he's done some amazing work
or he definitely should've been
nominated it's not surprising Reus
almighty has way more strings to us both
and just being in particular carries
roles in The Truman Show and Eternal
Sunshine of the spotless mind number 28
mass's is a gay guy who keeps breaking
out that one he's a great amazing
amazing yeah what's that one called a
gay guy break that a guy that breaks a
ghoul goes west because the name of that
movie yet he's never even had a chance
to get his hands on an Oscar like a
much-loved character of his we just
can't lie
[Music]
number three Marilyn Monroe not
surprising either ago she was the
epitome of the Hollywood lifestyle
fashion arising but she never sure the
chance of scoring the industry's
greatest accessories
[Music]
Prefer Blondes
what's the academy preferred other
actors baby I'm through some like it hot
earned her a Golden Globe but the
Academy didn't like it enough
shortlisted for more Globes and twice by
BAFTA Munroe rewrote the rules of cinema
but couldn't cracked its supreme
accolade public image and all that can
affect your chances
[Music]
number two Christopher Lee whoa
the first Christopher Lee film was
released in 1948 the last in 2015 he was
never nominated after 150 years he
credits with native owner collected
across a career spanning seven decades
that's really shocking that's that's
shocking he was a knight wiser would
become a the recipient of the back to
fellowship Lifetime Achievement Award
but not a single Oscar nomination was
ever his that's pretty surprising golden
guiding golden eyes one shot the real
bad guys in the otherwise much
celebrated Christopher Lee story are
surely the Academy yeah
before we unveil our number ones hick
here are some honorable mentions Oh mr.
Collins has been gulled will sleep
soundly if not they will arrest the
cabinet the public outcry will be
deafening maybe then the world will
listen I'm talking myself on a regular
base he's on his pass oh he's on his
path wait am i hell does this video this
is just [ __ ] winning boss but she was
a job this is an old video I could have
sworn ok number one Donald Sutherland
huh I am surprised it's time to
appreciate the most underappreciated
early work for those fight scene the
Oscar short list selection town such as
mash Kelly's heroes and the eagle has
landed
my place with a bloody British Empire
don't flick it on my own two feet
well he's well known to 21st century
audiences because of roles in Cold
Mountain and The Hunger Games franchise
sure cold manna that's where we all
millennium always at the top of his game
he not only deserves an Oscar nomination
he deserves to win one will you play me
something something peaceful look over
it's too damn bad you should come inside
do you agree with our list which
overlooked actor did we overlooked in
future offices which one of it I want if
you attempt to prevent me I certainly
shoot you for more top tens that you
will appreciate published with yes Smith
ever nominee right
do you watch with Olli he got on there
for ya the dark side of the booth
Denzel ever won any nominee for a
pursuit of happiness hey I am Bill Smith
you know Jeff Goldblum has never been
nominated for an Oscar that's not true
Gregory he's actually been nominated for
best short film what
yeah that's information I had prepared
of case you should bring his name up you
mean we didn't jump cut from a Google
search no not at all what are you talk
what's Google oh it's like Napster
really so you can just download anything
under like naps damn and Michael B
Jordan has never been nominated either
but he's on his way anyway there are
some good names on this list I feel like
John Goodman was the one that shocked me
the most actually sure that yeah I gotta
make disclosure here's the one whose
career I'm most familiar with more than
Donald Sutherland who they seem to
really be gung-ho about if he was the
number one who should have been
nominated but John Goodman's a
surprising one to me but then when I
think about that's true like he was
mainly known for Roseanne playing
Roseanne on the show Roseanne he was
great and mr. by that much so he's had
some great dramatic work when I think of
John Goodman I'll take a funny man from
Roseanne I think of those oscar-worthy
performances that just really come to
mind and like the crazy character she's
played over the years that provided a
lot of dramatic wait yeah I guess maybe
I'd see Achilles heel of John Goodman is
that he's really good at showing up and
playing very specific character type
roles bringing a lot of nuance to them
let's like a lot of what he does with
the Coen brothers so I guess maybe the
roles are either too small or too
specific or something yeah also John
Rowe - like I think 10 Cloverfield Lane
had an early release date and it's also
a specific type of genre so I feel like
that's why he probably wasn't even
talked about at all when I walk away
from that movie I'm like Jonathan's been
brilliant in this film is brilliant they
don't nominate they don't nominate
February movies forget him
Tom Hardy be nominee
like there are certain actors on this
list where they just kind of make sense
that they just haven't recognized them
I'm in the category of it they should
have been recognized at the same time
with knowing how weird the Academy
Awards are it's one thing to go after
the genres of film they tend to work in
like Jim Carrey has such an image of
being this slapstick weirdo then he does
like an occasional great drama once in a
while so I'm like I kind of get out why
the Academy just doesn't recognize him
for the work he does yeah but then I
think of someone like Jonah Hill who
gets nominated for Moneyball I'm like oh
right in it don't think it's great in
Moneyball you know yeah maybe this is
because Jonah Hill has never been quite
as broad and slapstick as Jim Carrey but
it is kind of perplexing yeah the
Academy seems to love one actor we got
to know through comedy much more than a
differe prolific one yeah or Mia Farrow
is another one where I find that
surprising like I watched Rosemary's
Baby last year for the first time and I
was just under the impression she liked
that way how much of a classic that film
is dick move she carries rosemary and
she's in like every single scene of that
lengthy film that is a classic I just
assumed she was nominated and to find
out she wasn't for that film
specifically kind of shocks me a walk
raúl juliá as general bison John Claude
Van Damme played an American general who
had a French accent and should be
nominated yeah in Bisons ass so hard
show that clip like that's his
oscar-winning Martin Sheen yeah that's
another one there like half this list is
comprised of actors who are prolific
enough that I just assumed that they'd
all had yeah nomination especially for
Apocalypse Now everyone
always reference yeah the brando
performance the five minutes of screen
time that he was nominated I wonder if
he's bitter about that it's like you
overshadowed me for the movie I'm in
most all of us it was kind of the same
way with Ray Liotta and Goodfellas I
think De Niro got recognized Pesci has
an Oscar or is now rightfully so that do
you think Liotta should have gotten lead
actor nomination yeah you know and Ray
Liotta was a nominated for an Oscar ever
and I think he should have been
nominated freakin fellas
that's his movie he's amazing Goodfellas
they were just like we can't how many
Goodfellas too many times everything was
nominated for the star of the line
they're like alright you almost made it
you right there you're number six in the
category I don't know how the Oscars
ever really worked you can look at
someone's career and go I can't believe
they weren't nominated but rare can I
actually go they should have been
nominated for this movie I don't care
what category of actors they were up
against I find it very hard for Ray
Liotta to not be nominated for
Goodfellas Marilyn Monroe that's another
one words kind of conflicting for me
because I'm like she's done some great
work surprising she didn't get an Oscar
nod same time it's not surprising that
was one of the ones I was less surprised
about yeah if you're like a Marilyn
Monroe fan you know how great she is but
people might not have taken her as
seriously as a true actually should they
when she had to work to be taken
seriously but the image that was laid
out for her was sex appeal
mhm you know like me that's why no one
takes me seriously I feel like we live
in a society where they keep sexualizing
men like myself always it's not fair
they watch Christopher Lee Christopher
Lee films you have to do you believe the
most surprised yeah cuz I was like this
dude put in like so the thing about the
Oscars is when you boil it down to just
one year at a time I can kind of see
then how okay you only have five slots
yeah things happen maybe there were just
five other actor
really captivated people at the time I
don't know in the moment what's gonna be
great but Christopher Lee is had so many
roles and so much time to be nominated
like I'm surprised he never even got the
we should have nominated you by now
here's a nomination or that a Lifetime
Achievement Award maybe he got one I
don't know or something yeah that's
he's Christopher friggin Lee hole oh
yeah guys who do you think should have
been nominated by now I feel like
Michael B Jordan will get a nomination
down the road like that's pretty obvious
Sam Rockwell did win he did win Jake
Gyllenhaal has been nominated but hasn't
won
I mean sometimes too we can forget just
how good a performance is like when we
kind of just expect it out of them you
know ha ha yeah it's like that's what it
was for Gary Oldman for so long
like oh yeah he transforms into
characters that's his job he's great all
the time this is a surprising maybe
that's it maybe if you're just always
great maybe you need to do something
like completely astonishing to finally
get out of the mold of course he's great
because Jim Carrey's dramatic work for
something like Truman Show or I could
even see the genre of eternal sunshine
that hits a dramatic performance yeah
but it's John rabe it's like fantasy
kind of quirky sense of its world I can
see as well yeah you know the super
would Jim Furyk and working like I don't
know some [ __ ] justification I think
that's like I think a Jonah Hill feel
like everyone's like he's it a drama
what and then it was a drama you know
yeah The Truman Show was it's kinda
dramedy you know I feel like Jim
Carrey's image just works against him
with people like the Academy yeah you
know and and again I don't know what
other films were up against his dramas
those years but hey you know what guys
put it down to comes below for us you
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Belka subscribe
buttons are broken and check us out on
patreon we got full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is and music video
coverage would love to have you
on anything ask you a few questions